du beurre tu es toujours joyeux
anniversaire paul langeois joyeux
anniversaire au bébé si vous avez vu on
a fait quand même des petits plats dans
les grands pour vous c'est merveilleux
alors oui aller vite pour les 25 ans du
big band café vous avez prévu ce
vendredi une grosse fête gratuite
c'était important un anniversaire si on
fait payant s'est passé c'est plutôt un
anniversaire donc il fallait bien sûr
qu'on invite le public à venir donc on a
une grosse soirée plein de surprises du
décor des dj qui vont mixer un peu 25
ans de musique comme les 25 ans du bbcd
goodies en vois tu en veux tu en voilà
un animateur de foule ou des blind test
voilà l'idée c'est que tout le monde
vient de faire la fête avec nous et
c'est pour nous une vraie fête
d'anniversaire et samedi vous inviter
les gens à bien découvrir un petit but
des coulisses samedi visite des
coulisses parce que c'est souvent aussi
ce qui plaît ainsi connaître un peu
l'envers du décor et puis aller à la
rencontre du de l'équipe du bébé c'est
parce que le dcc pas que moi c'est aussi
des salariés qui sont à vocation bien
longtemps aussi et elle sait pouvoir les
rencontrer un sonorisateur aller visiter
les coulisses vous demander
des anecdotes etc c'est recevoir le
public avec déjà quasi plein faut pas
tarder on a deux visites en fait en
rajouter le troisième
[Musique]
ma fille
et prochains concerts ici au vent de
café aussi 28 mars
le piment de café 28 basse donc
dépêchez-vous parce que les places vont
partir vite
alors ça bouge dans l'orne c'est le
printemps
c'est un formidable festival comme
chaque année c'est la combine et iem
édition fait la 13e avec ce soir les
fouteurs de joie mais c'est dans l'orne
et c'est un spectacle de chansons
évidemment mais c'est un spectacle c'est
très drôle
alexis hk formidable guitariste et
chanteur et interprète et par le dîner à
son pote imaginaire comme un ours
bipolaire c'est une nouvelle création un
nouveau spectacle qui s'appelle comme un
ours
une première j'ai plus du brassens et
plus et chez vraiment ces jours ci ce
sont ses nouvelles chansons avant que
son album sorte à l'automne je suis pas
très sûrs d'eux l'idée en fait les
facteurs chevaux c'est un groupe qui a
une musique assez atypique plutôt folk
des chansons des petits contes en fait
mis en musique et il souhaite toujours
jouer dans des lieux atypiques puisque
c'est une formule musicale atypique qui
veulent jouer dans des lieux atypiques
mme envolée face à ligne au décret eh
bien merci beaucoup clair le printemps
de la chanson dans l'ordre c'est
jusqu'au 1er avril venez vraiment dans
l'ordre pour assister à ses concerts
je cherche mon chemin j'en vois qu'un
lundi soir au café des images la liberté
si je veux le nouveau film de laurent
brard et marc rapide tournée dans la
région avec des gens la région c'est au
café des images à 19 heures hérouville
saint clair c'est qui je sais pas moi
[Musique]
mystique et samedi soir au soubock à
coville qui fait un spécial blues
festival dès ce soir
et demain mystique qui est fred atom au
soubock de comines
[Musique]